Live. So let's go live right
now. Start streaming. Good.
The event is starting,
I think on the Stream is actually
going to start in a second.
It says it's starting. Yes, it started
great. Okay. Okay. Hello world.
It's Saroj. Welcome to my live
stream on Google. Dopamine.
This is a new framework that
came out of Google research.
There was this blog post
that explained how it works.
And in this live stream we're going to,
I'm going to talk about how it works.
So I'm going to dive into its modules.
It's features of,
we're going to talk a little bit,
not a little bit.
We're going to talk about
reinforcement learning in general. Uh,
and then we are going to code it out.
So we're going to use Google's Colab
to code out a very simple agent
implementation in the browser.
Anybody can do this. I want,
if you're watching this,
I want you to do this with me.
So go to colab.research.google.com and
open up a notebook and just start and
start coding with me. Okay? So,
and I'm also taking in feedback
from the last live stream.
So I don't want to be as sporadic with
like looking at audience comments and
just being all over the place. So here's
how we're going to structure this.
The first part of this tutorial,
this lecture is going to be me
explaining how the framework works, uh,
and how reinforcement
learning in general works.
Then I'm going to take a short Q and a,
then I'm going to code this thing out
in the browser as a very simple agent so
we can get a feel for how
this framework works. Uh,
and then after training I'm
going to take another Q and. A.
And at the end they'll
take another Q. And. A.
And I'm going to start off with just
two questions to go ahead and ask two
questions. I'll answer those and then
we'll get right into the lecture. Okay.
So I'll definitely minimize this chat
window when I'm talking because I saw that
the, uh, recorded viewers didn't
like that that much, you know,
seeing all these comments come in. So, um,
I'm very excited to talk
about this by the way,
because reinforcement learning has been
just pure reinforcement learning has
been the forgotten technique
I think about AI of,
of Ai because there was the
resurgence in deep learning, right?
So let's start off with this timeline,
right?
So there was the resurgence in neural
networks with deep learning around like,
oh six or oh seven, uh, and then, uh,
there was a resurgence in deep
reinforcement learning around,
I think it was 2013 when a deep
mind release, the deep Q learner.
And so it went from like reinforcement
learning in the 60s to neural networks to
taking reinforcement learning,
applying it to neural networks.
But no one in general has really
focused on reinforcement learning,
just pure reinforcement learning.
Like if you look at the content out there
in terms of blog posts, in terms of, um,
videos, in terms of anything
for reinforcement learning,
it's so small compared to the amount
of content available for supervised
learning, right? Neural
networks, et cetera.
So there definitely needs to be more
content around reinforcement learning.
And I promise you I'm a bar.
I'm going to bring that to the world.
So starting with this course
and then more and more coming.
So about those two questions
before we get started here.
The first question is most important
things for a software engineer to get into
data science.
That's a great question.
Data Science is similar and different
to software engineering and software
engineering. You're not doing, you're
not doing any data cleaning, right?
Any data preprocessing which takes up
the majority unfortunately have a data
scientist time.
So one important thing would just be
to use the Google data sets search,
download some datasets,
and then use something very simple like
psychic learn in Google Colab to just
hack together a very simple linear
regression models. So that's a,
that's a good starting point.
Second question is,
do I need a GPU to run what you were
about to do today? Can I use my laptop?
Only you can use your mobile phone
because the GPU is actually in the browser
with colab. So you don't need a Gpu. Okay.
I would actually not recommend
you using a mobile phone.
I would recommend you to use a, um, any
kind of basic laptop. All right, so,
right. So I could talk to you
guys all day, but I'm, I'm,
I'm being more disciplined here.
Okay. So this is for the greater good.
So I'm going to minimize the chat window
and then I'll get right back into it.
All right.
So like I said,
deep reinforcement learning is what's
responsible for these big victories in Ai.
And uh, it started with the deep
queue network that deepmind release.
And it was so good that Google bought
deep mind for $500 million just because of
that algorithm,
because that one algorithm could,
could succeed in 60,
I think it was 60 different Atari game
environments. It was, it was generalized,
it could, it could learn how to master
any of these games, one algorithm.
And that was very exciting. And
so what deep Q used to, to do,
what it did was three specific techniques.
It used replay memory,
large scale distributed training,
and a dis,
a distributional modeling
method. Okay. And so this,
this all ties into dopamine by the way.
Okay.
This is not just like me
going off on a tangent here.
Deep Q used these three techniques,
right? So replay memory, uh, is it's,
it's a really,
it's a really cool idea.
So we are in week one
of this move 37 course.
So don't expect me to like
go all deep into deep,
deep learning or deep reinforcement
learning right now. I will, uh,
but to start off with, um, I'm just going
to like touch on these little concepts.
So replay memory is saying,
um,
let's store all of those states actions
and rewards in this giant array while we
are learning. So there's two processes
happening when it comes to replay memory.
There's the, the, the, the cue learning.
So it's the process of learning what the
appropriate state action parish should
be, uh, for whatever your environment is.
And then next to that is this idea of
storing all of those states actions and
rewards that the agent is
executing in that environment.
And so interpolated these two techniques,
acting and learning helps
improve the policy. So that's
the basic idea. All right?
So when it comes to deep
reinforcement learning,
all you need to know is
that neural networks are an
agent that can learn to map
state action pairs to rewards, right? So
if we are in a state and an environment,
right? So let's say we are in grid world,
right? We're in the bottom left corner.
We want to perform an action, like
move up or move to the right. Uh,
we need to know, um, what would be the
best action to do depending on the reward,
right?
What's gonna Maximize reward?
So if we take the state action pair
from this state, move up, you know,
or from this state moved to the right,
and then we take the reward
plus one zero or negative one.
If we can learn that mapping,
then we can find the
optimal queue function,
which is going to give us
the optimal policy. Uh,
and that's what neural networks can do.
And there are a lot of ways to
approximate that function. But remember,
neural networks are universal function
approximators and that's why they work so
well when it comes to reinforcement
learning to learn what that cue function
should be.
That's it.
Don't worry if you don't understand
anything I just said that was just me like
taking like a leap into the future, but
now we're going to come back. Right?
So because those techniques
required such rapid experimentation,
the researchers at Google decided that
they needed a framework that could
encapsulates the types of iterative,
fast design updates that they required,
right?
So if you look at reinforcement
learning frameworks today,
they're not very flexible.
Um,
they require you to construct a mark
of decision process from scratch. Um,
and then there's a lot of like,
just fill our code that you have to write
and then let's say you're writing say
policy improvement and in
policy evaluation and you know,
that's policy iteration as a,
as a dynamic programming technique.
If you want to modify that
and turn that into a say,
Monte Carlo technique or some
other technique, it's certainly,
it's going to require a
lot of code refactoring.
So there needs to be a way to
enable rapid experimentation.
So TLDR needs more flexibility,
stability,
and reproducibility,
right? Let's be real here.
Code reproducibility when it comes
to our El research is abysmal, right?
Just try, just try reimplementing. Um,
some technique using a famous RL
paper, it won't work because, uh,
there's a lot of problems there,
right? Not, not that I won't work,
but it's very hard.
So this is going to help with that.
So if we look at this framework and
they've got it on get hub, it's brand new.
It was just uploaded 19 days ago.
They've got some great documentation here,
and then they've got some instructions
on how to install it locally,
depending on what your environment
is. Let me, let me make this bigger,
make this bigger as well.
And let me make sure everybody's
doing well. All right, cool.
All right, good. So what
does it feature? So if we,
if we go to this folder called dopamine,
so I want you to go to this folder.
These are the, these are the
features that it provides. Okay.
So basically Tldr,
dopamine is taking open Ai's gym,
uh, environment. So all those games
and tensorflow and combining them,
I know that's a very gross
of, um, that's a, that's a,
that's a gross oversimplification
of what the framework is. But Tldr,
highest level, you got some
environments, you got some agents,
let's combine that together and
then let's create this RL framework.
So the first part of what it
offers are these agents. Okay.
So all of these agents are basically
variations of the deep Q learner,
right? So deep Q like I talked
about, uh, was deep mines, you know,
famous algorithm that beat
all those Atari Games.
So it's got a collection of those pre
coded and those agents are commented very,
very well. I've been looking through
this code, check this out. I mean it,
it's even got references to the
paper and each function, um,
the arguments are all explained.
If we go into these, um,
functions like build networks,
well documented code. Um,
so that's,
that's very cool.
So it's got a bunch of agents in there
and which specific agents doesn't have,
well, it's got the deep Q network.
Right? So given some, given some,
uh, pixels from some frames of a game, uh,
decide what the appropriate
action should be.
So a neural network will learn to
approximate the Q function based on those
pixel value.
So it's learning that mapping and then
taking those pixel values and converting
them through actions and
whatever action space, uh,
whenever environments specific
action space, there is now there,
there's also see 51, which is
a, which is basically deep,
do the same thing as deep queue,
except instead of approximated x,
instead of x approximating
expected future reward values,
it generates the whole distribution
over possible outcomes.
So what this allows for
is, um, more variability in
what those rewards could be.
It's not just a scaler, it's a
distribution of possibilities,
right? Like, uh, uh,
a Gaussian or etc. There's also rainbow.
So Rainbow,
uh, there've been a bunch of extensions
to the deep Q network. Um, no priority,
no dueling, don't worry if you
don't understand any of these terms.
There's a lot of terms to Grok to
understand and reinforcement learning.
And I'm going to go over
the most important ones,
so don't worry. Okay. Just,
let's just, let's just, let's just chill
here. And this is this a lot to take in.
I know this is a lot to take
in, but, but bear with me. So,
so rainbow basically combined
six different techniques
into one algorithm and it
outperforms the rest. And then there's
implicit Quanta, which is very new.
This actually just came out, I think it
was last month at the ICML conference. Uh,
but it's similar in that it's
kind of based off the idea of,
of the deep Q network
accepted approximates the full
Quan tile function for the
state action return distribution.
So again,
the idea of a distribution is used for
the rewards over a single scalar value.
And don't worry if you don't
understand any of that, but anyway,
it offers those agents
encapsulated already coded
for you and we can then build
our own agents off of those.
So that's that.
The other thing it provides
besides these pre coded agents,
our environments,
so under a tare,
preprocessing is not necessary for us
run experiments, trained the Pi's. Uh,
okay. So basically it's
going to run a UN, UN, UN,
whichever environment
that you'd like from.
So there are 60 different Atari games
that you could use fright from the Atari
learning environment, the Ale,
the arcade learning environment,
and it's using Jin. Jin
is basically just, um, uh,
a configuration framework for python.
You're going to see gin,
like kind of sprinkled in this code where,
you know,
if you have a lot of parameters to be
able to easily replace those parameters
with new values, uh, would be efficient,
right? So in the case of neural networks,
so we have possibly many
layers with possibly many
different types of activation
functions. If we could just plug in,
play different activation functions,
that would be great for research, right?
And so that's what Jen helps with.
So there's that. Um, there's,
and there's common, right?
So in addition to having that environment
and a bunch of agents to act in their
environment,
it's got a common library which is
going to provide us with logging and
checkpointing, right? So any
kind of debugging we need
to do right? Experiments,
statistics, agent variables, including
the tensor flow graph, itself's replay,
buffered data,
right?
So sometimes having a replay memory
can be a giant memory footprint, right?
So imagine just storing all the states,
all the actions, all the rewards.
Eventually that's going to become
a giant table in memory. So, um,
this helps minimize that. So
that's under common. Okay.
So, um, that's under common right here,
checkpoint or iterations to sticks, et
cetera. And then there's replay memories.
So replay memory, there's
actually different types of
replay memory techniques,
circular replay, prioritize,
replaced some tree. Now,
I haven't talked about any of these
before and I cannot wait to start talking
about them, but, uh, they're
all under here as python files.
And of course there's tests sing, right,
for production use cases, et Cetera,
et cetera.
So that was it for that.
Now.
Good.
Okay. So, all right, so that's it for the
framework. We're going to start coding,
but I want to go over some very
important concepts right now. Um,
when it comes to reinforcement
learning. Okay. So, like I said,
there are a ton of different,
uh,
techniques that we could use for
reinforcement learning, right?
Different types of replay memory,
deep cue learning,
writes a deep reinforcement learning in
general, Implicit Quan tile, you know,
et cetera. All of these
techniques. But really there are,
there are four concepts
that are the most important.
They are objectively the most important
concepts to know in reinforcement
learning. And here's what they are.
One, the Mark Haub decision process.
That's the first one to a policy.
Three,
the state value function
and three and four,
the action value function. Okay.
And five, the bellman equation.
So five, actually there are five
really important concepts, you know,
and if you know those five,
everything else is based
off of these five concepts.
The mark of decision process date with me,
the mark of decision process. Say, okay,
the policy,
the state value function,
the action value function
and the bellman equation,
there's four of them. So I was
actually pretty amazing. Uh,
once you start to get into this RL world,
you start framing life and reality in
terms of our l and you start seeing how
the mark of decision process is a great
mathematical framework for framing. Um,
any kind of learning agent in an
environment. And a, it's just,
it's just beautiful. The more,
the more you stare at this stuff,
the more beautiful it seems.
And I guess that applies to all sorts
of science and math. But in particular,
reinforcement learning is a very,
um,
this theory that the theories that have
been, it's been built on are amazing.
And you know, I was kind of skeptical at
first because I thought, you know who,
who says the mark of decision process
should be the way that we're going? Right?
What if we just discard that and
think of an entirely new framework?
But you know what?
They really put a lot of thoughts into
this and there's a reason that it's stuck
around for so long because it's a
very simple yet elegant and extendable
framework, mathematical framework,
right? So in any environment,
you have a set of states, right? Whatever
the state could be. If you're skiing,
the states could be skiing, down, skiing,
up. I don't think skiing up is a thing.
Skiing to the size, you to the right,
you have a set of actions push forward,
push back, um, look right.
Whatever those actions should be.
You have a transition function that says
what's the probability of going to a
certain state?
If you take an action in this state,
you have a starting state distribution,
which we're not going
to talk about right now.
You have a discount factor which says
if you're in a state,
right, if you're in a state,
let's just talk about grid world.
I think red world is a great
introductory example here in grid world.
Looks like this where if you're in a
grid world and you're trying to get from
point a to point B, you could go
up, down, left, right? Then, uh,
so just that's,
that's the framework here.
What should be the next state that you
go to, right? If you're in one state,
what would be the best next state to
go to to optimize your reward? And
what the discount factor does is it is,
it helps to compute the expected
cumulative reward,
the expected cumulative discounted reward.
So it could be discounted,
it could not be discounted. So there's
so much to explain here. So like, okay,
if you're in a state, so check
this out. If you're in a state,
in an environment and you want to see
what would be the expected set of rewards,
I would get from going from say,
you know,
let's say I'm in this bottom corner right
here and I want to eventually end up
in the top right corner.
So all of these are states,
all of these squares are states and I'm
gonna earn a reward based on which state
I'm in. So if I could look ahead
into the future and say, well,
based on this state that I'm in right now,
if I were to go to that state,
that state that say that's
an eventually to the end,
what would be the total
reward that I would get?
And so we could sum up all
of those rewards, right?
And then we could add them up
and it becomes a scalar value.
And that's the ex that's
called the return.
So the return is the
cumulative future reward.
So if we look ahead into the future and
we try to sum up all of those rewards,
that's going to be the
cumulative future reward.
Now we can apply what's called a discount
factor and that's a scalar value.
Usually it's 0.9 as it is,
but it can be pointed whatever
in terms of research papers.
And what that will do
is it's going to say,
how much should we take into consideration
the short term versus the future.
And so it's a,
it's a,
it's a variable that tweaks how much an
agent cares about maximizing for short
term rewards versus future rewards,
longterm awards.
And that depends on the
environment that you're in. Okay.
So that's the idea of a
mark Haub decision process.
An agent is in an environment,
it takes an action in that environment
based on its state and it tries to
maximize for the reward value,
right? So in a given state,
it will take an action to go to the next
state such that that that action will
maximize its reward.
Speaking of that, okay,
for an example,
racing is another example,
but I think I just gave the grid world
example, which is a, which is pretty nice,
right? So what do we call that? Right? So
once an agent knows, right, it nodes the,
the, the best action
to take. Let's say we,
we have trained our agent very well and
it knows what the best action should be.
Now it knows exactly what to do. What
do we call that? We call that a policy.
Okay.
That is called a policy.
What the policy does is
it says it knows exactly,
it knows exactly,
um,
what is the best action to take
given this state, right? It's,
it's a function that takes in a state
and an action and returns the probability
of taking that action in that state.
So what it's going to do is going to
take the action that gives the highest of
achieving that maximum reward, and that's
the action that it's going to take.
So get given a state is going to say
all of these actions are possible,
but this particular action is going to
maximize future reward and that is the
optimal policy. And we have to learn
what that optimal policy will be.
And that optimal policy is a function.
Right?
Okay.
So how do we compute that optimal policy?
So we as humans, and this is, this is,
this is what I'm talking about,
about relating it to reality.
We as humans have an optimal policy,
right?
So given this environment
of teaching this, um, I,
the state of teaching,
I know to make the next,
the next action to take is to continuously
scroll down and continue teaching
because that's going to maximize my reward
in terms of the amount of people that
are learning this.
That's my objective and that's my policy.
That's a very abstract metta. But anyway,
you get what I'm saying? I hopefully.
Um, so how do we, let me just make
sure everybody's on board here.
Everybody's good.
Okay. So how do we compute
that policy now? Okay.
The way we compute the policy is by using
value functions and don't go anywhere
because here is where I think a lot of
people give up on our El because the idea
of a value function can be
confusing, right? There's,
there's some terms that we have
to essentially memorize here,
but what I'm saying is this
is totally doable. Okay.
There are two value functions,
so right?
So remember an agent is in an environment
and it's trying to pick the best
action to take.
So how is it going to do that?
How is it going to learn this policy of
what's the best action to take? Well,
it needs a way of evaluating both
the state that it's in right now and
okay,
what the value of each action
it could take would be,
so there are two value functions.
You have the state value function.
Let me maximize this.
Okay,
let me just,
these equations are what matter here.
So I'm just going to make
that big. You have. So the,
the equation right here at the top,
that is the state value function in one
way to think about this is by using an
apostrophe.
So say so by saying that the value
function actually belongs to the state.
So it's the state's value function.
So the state has its own value function,
okay? And so what it does is it describes
the value of a state when following a
policy,
it's the expected return when starting
from state ass according to our policy,
right?
So what is going to do is going to
evaluate the current state that I'm in by
looking at all the possible actions I
could be taking in any direction in this
action space and saying,
here's a scalar value that represents
the value of being in this state.
But if I was in a different state,
then I have a different value for
all those actions, right? So it, it,
it measures the value of
this particular state.
But notice that in order to measure
the value of this particular state,
we need to find a way to measure the
value of each action that we would take in
that state. And that's where the action
value function comes into play. Again,
think of it like an apostrophe.
It belongs to the action.
So it's the actions value function.
So the state has its own value function
and then the action has its own value
function.
And these two value functions combined
help us approximate the policy,
right?
Because a policy consists of
both value function functions.
What's the value of the state?
And to compute that,
I need to know the value of each
action I could be taking in this state.
And that's how they both
relate to each other now,
okay, the last part, that
was four or five, the last
part, the bellman equations.
Okay. So there are four of them,
but we're going to use two of them.
So how do we compute those value
functions, correct, or rights?
How do we compute those value functions?
Well,
we need a way of relating the
current state that we're in to, uh,
to other states. And if we were able to
frame it that way, if we were able to say,
here is what this state equals two and
here is how it relates to other states,
well then we could, we could then compute
what the optimal values should be.
So what the Bellmont equation lets us do
is it lets us express values of states
as values of other states. So it
relates a current state to other states.
And if we can do that,
if we can do that,
then we can characterize
fully the learning problem.
And once we've characterized in terms
of mathematically defined how these two
value functions related to the
policy in this specific environment,
then we can compute them using a technique
like say dynamic programming or Monte
Carlo techniques or salsa
or deep learning, et cetera.
But what the bellman equation does is it
lets us frame the problem in a way that
these, um, these functions relate to
each other. So we have first of all,
the optimal value function,
which relates to the optimal action
value function. The Q function,
the optimal value function is equivalent
to the action that's going to give us
the highest probability,
the Max probability of
achieving our reward.
And we can then further break
that down into this last equation.
And this is how it relates.
Using the bellman equation,
we can compute what the optimal state
value function should be using that action
value function. And that's the bellman
equation. And once we have both of those,
we've got our optimal policy.
Okay, that's the highest level.
Now I've got some great videos coming out
on both of these concepts this weekend.
Can't wait for that.
All right,
so now I'm going to take some Q and a
before I start coding in this framework.
All right, let me see how many people are
in the room here. Oh, 801 hi. Hello world.
800 people are here. I love
it. I love it. Um, yes,
this video will be, so let me take two
questions before we start coding. Okay.
Okay. Here's a great
question. Sh show. It asks,
what if the R L agent chooses Paul
a policy with the most reward?
But in that time the environment changes
a bit and the chosen policy is not the
best.
Great question.
So there are two types of policies on
deterministic policy and a stochastic
policy. Okay. And depending
on your environment, you're
going to want to pick one.
A deterministic policy
will be predictable.
You're going to know what the
outputs are going to be us.
The castic policy on the other hand,
is unpredictable and it's usually
leveraging the usage of um,
distribution, no values.
And so you'd want,
he's a sarcastic policy in that context.
Second question,
what is Pi doing there in the equations?
Okay.
Pi is not the, yes. Okay, check this out.
This pi value does not mean pie like 3.14.
That's another confusing thing.
We should've picked a different,
um, we should've picked a different,
a symbol for the optimal policy,
but that's, it's too late.
The Pi symbol in the context of
reinforcement learning means the policy,
not 3.14. So just take that out
of your head for right now. Okay.
Now dopamine versus open Ai, Jim. Um,
it wraps, it literally
wraps open Ai. Jim, open Ai.
Jim is one of the dependencies here,
right? And we can do that by saying, uh,
we can look for what that is by saying,
uh,
import gym inside of this repository.
And there it is. This repository
is importing gym, right?
And this trained up py import gym. There
we go, right? So it's important Jim.
So it's, it's, it's contained.
Jim is contained here. All right,
let's start coding guys.
So here we go. All right,
we're going to build a simple
agent using Google dopamine.
So the first step is to install our
packet. Let me just a short Q and a here.
So the first step is for us to install
our packages and we have some packages to
install the me make this
bigger here. Um, all right.
So the first package we're going to
install is the of the dopamine library.
So dopamine,
our l,
and then we're going to
install the c make library,
which is one of dopamine is dependencies
as well as the arcade learning
environment. Okay,
that's going to help us.
No cache directory.
Pip install.
There we go.
[inaudible]
so let's let this, uh, that,
those are our three dependencies
that we need to install. Still Real.
We'll let those install. Great.
They were just installed. Okay.
So that's the first part. Now let's
import our dependencies. Okay.
So the first one, we're going to
import his num Pi for Matrix math.
The second one we're going to import
his hoe ass took for us to help load our
files.
The third one is our dopamine framework,
specifically the Dq an agent,
which we're going to use to test as
a baseline against our simple agent.
We're also going to use
the Atari a environment.
So the run experiment is the function
is the execution engine that's going to
relate the agent and the
environment together.
Then we have our,
um,
we have a little helper
functions specifically for Colab,
which is going to let us a download
data directly into our colab as well as
visualize it very easily.
And then we have this important flags
just for like warnings that we could
potentially have
[inaudible]
dopamine. Right. That's
what I wanted to import.
Okay,
good. Okay. Now we're going to
create our agent from scratch. Um,
but there's actually, oh, you know what,
I need to define, um, where
to store those training logs.
So we're going to store our training
logs in as temporary directory.
I'm going to call colab dope run.
Um,
and then which arcade environment should
we use? Let's use asterisks. Uh, there's,
we could use any of them asteroids or
any of them, but let's just use this one.
Okay. Make sure that works. Good. Alright,
so that's create our agent from
scratch now. So before we start,
I'm going to, let me make sure everybody
can see what I'm writing here. All good?
Everybody right?
All right,
so let's, Oh, also before we even do this,
let me also just quickly
show you tensor board.
So this is a premade notebook and um,
what it's going to allow us to do is
visualize this intense or board in the
browser. Okay? So, um,
this is something that
I been meaning to do.
So this is going to install
a bunch of dependencies.
It's my take a while. Uh,
and then when that's done,
dependencies of course,
take a while.
Okay.
I want to visualize asterisk.
Hasta
and so now it's training and then I'm
going to show you tense or board in the
browser. It's very cool. I just want to
just start off with something very visual,
um, before we go into other
things. Okay. So let that train.
Okay.
And let me continue creating my agent
here. So the first step for
us is to create a log path.
And what this is going to do is tell our
agent where to store. It's a
where to store the log data. Okay?
So I'm going to call it a basic agent
inside of this game environment.
And that's the log path are right.
Let me just remove this because I
need this full space here. Okay.
Log Path. Great. No,
let's create this agent.
So I'm going to call it a
basic agent. Basic agent. Now,
dopamine expects a certain,
um,
framework for defining our functions here.
And I'm going to,
what I'm gonna start off with is
defining what those functions should be.
Okay? So the first one
is choose actions. Um,
how to select an action.
Basically the next one is what
is the bundle and the checkpoint.
So this is when it
checkpoints during training.
Okay.
Uh, anything we should do, like
whenever we check point during training,
this is going to be a fired whenever.
Um,
we are saving something.
Actually I'll just put pass here cause
we don't really want to do anything. Um,
there's also load from, so whenever
we're loading from a checkpoint,
unbundle is going to be called. So
we want to do some, we might want to,
um, do something if, if we
are loading from a checkpoint,
any kind of cleanup or maybe reset
our environment or, you know,
depending on what we're doing, we
might want to, um, you know, there's,
there's any number of things that we
could be doing a, but for right now,
this simple agent on been dope.
We don't want to do anything.
All right? So there's that. There's also
began episodes. So whenever we, um, the,
what's the first action that we want
to take inside of this environment?
Okay.
Unused observation. All right. Pass.
And, um, there's one more
and that's the step function.
So we can update our policy here actually.
So given a reward for whatever environment
we're in, and this is where it's,
I'm inheriting from Open
Ai's gym environment, let's,
let's return what the
optimal action should be.
Okay.
Um,
and so that's really it for our,
this basic step and,
and, and once we have that, we
can then create another function.
But let me go back up here.
And so this is kind of the skeleton
that we need for Google dopamine, right?
And so this is, you know, a
way of defining a bunch of
whatever our technique we'll be.
Okay. So for this basic agent,
let's just choose a random action to take.
Very simple,
and then we could extend that to you say,
dynamic programming, value, iteration,
policy, iteration, any kind of these,
any of these very simple
planning techniques where
the entire mark of decision
process, all of those more
Covidien variables are known. Uh,
we can use something like dynamic
programming, but to start off with, let us
code up a very simple policy.
So we're going to first initialize our
tensor flow session and then we're going
to define this variable
called numb actions.
And what numb actions is going to tell us.
Is it going to say how many
possible actions can we take?
What is the possibility for this?
What is the realm of possibility
for this action space?
There's also switch Prob,
which tells us the probability of
switching actions in the next time step,
which we're going to use to
define what it's going to be.
And then we have our last action. And
so this is going to be our first action.
Actually.
I know it's kind of confusing,
but we're going to
initialize the last action,
which is going to be where we start from.
And so we're going to keep
continuously update it.
We're going to initialize it as random
and uh,
and then
well we'll start one more initialized
variable for to not debug.
We, we might want to debug, but we won't.
Okay,
so those are our initial actions.
Now let's define our policy.
Okay,
so define our policy. How do we choose
an action, right? Given the state,
how do we choose our action?
So here's what we're going to do.
Our policy is going to be so simple.
It's going to say,
let's pick some random number out there.
Okay, let's say NP dot. Random dot.
Random APP, great name by the way. Uh,
let's say if that number is less
than our switch probability,
which is also, um, which is what
we're going to define beforehand.
If it's less than that, okay? If it's,
if it's below our threshold
for switching actions,
let's set the last action we just
took to a new random action to take.
And,
and that's,
that action is going to be contained
inside the possibility of actions that we
could be taking.
And so if we go back to return,
so at the end we can return what
that new action is going to be,
which is stored in last action.
Okay. This is our policy.
We're essentially choosing a random action
as long as it fits into our threshold
for whatever we define switch prop to be,
it's going to be a value between zero
and 100 or zero and one a percentage.
That's it. That's our simple
policy. That's our mapping
of um, states to actions.
Okay. So, um, there's that. Um,
and then there's one more thing I need
to define here and the step function
which is going to return that.
In fact, I already have that.
And so once we have that,
then we can talk about what
the class should be, right?
So now that we have let
we make sure that works.
Of course
self dot switch prob
says invalid syntax of course because
right?
Okay.
Self dot switch prob boom.
[inaudible]
wow, that worked great. Okay,
now we've defined that and so now
we can create our basic agents.
We've defined our agents class and now
we can define our, we'll create an agent.
So given our tents are closed session,
given the environment that we're in,
let's return a basic agent object using
the tensorflow session session and we're
going to define the number of actions
we could take by looking at the
environment that we're in, looking at the
action space and returning that number.
And then we're going to define
a switch probability of say 0.2.
And that's going to help us
return a basic agent. Now
once we have that,
we can now create an
agent using that function.
So run experiment is that dopamine native
function to create a runner object.
And so if we look inside the runner object
of,
hold on,
this is actually super exciting to me.
So like I could take forever on this
if we look. So what did we just use?
We use the runner.
What was it?
It was a tare run experiment.
So this is the runner object. And so
if we look inside of here, we can see,
let me hold on, we can see those.
Okay.
Those functions that we defined earlier,
like what were they called?
They were called began episode
began episodes. So right there,
right?
These,
these functions are then called inside of
the runner object and they're utilized.
So that's why I'm saying that there is
a skeleton here that we are following
such that it's going to work for this
specific framework. And um, right.
And so this is, this is,
this is a good thing.
So we're going to create a basic agent.
We're going to define the log path and
now we're going to define a bunch of 'em,
a bunch of variables here.
So the game name is going to
be the game that we defined.
The um, number of
iterations is going to, oh,
by the way, I was running
this tender board. I forgot
about that. Let's start it.
Okay, so what, this, what, okay,
what this is doing is
it's going to visualize,
uh,
some training in the browser.
So trained models in the
browser using tensor board.
Anybody can now run tensorflow board
in the browser. Check this out.
This is real time right here.
We can add in some filters.
I S. Z, I dunno. So just like that,
we've got a bunch of scalars we
could change the smoothing values,
get more smooth, get
less smooth, checkout,
different runs until these are all the
different runs for Rainbow Implicit Quan
tile.
There's agents that I talked about before
and they've even got this great little
link here where we can just see
for any environments that we're in,
I make this bigger.
Let's say it's the game.
Frostbites we can see how each of
those agents performs in the specific
environment that we're in.
And it looks like right here.
Rainbow outperformed the rest.
So just wanted to quickly
show you that by the way,
they have these colabs inside of the um,
framework.
Go to dopamine colab and they've
got several right here. Okay,
so check those out. So, um, where was I?
So the number of iterations are going to
be, let's say 200, uh, the training steps.
And I'm going to answer questions in
a second. Like I said, after training,
I'm going to answer some questions here.
Or evaluation steps are going to be,
let's say 10,
and then the Max steps per
episode are going to be 100.
Okay.
Um, yeah, that's not
gonna work. Of course.
What is the problem here?
Right, I see that. But where,
where's the issue?
No registered environment asterisk.
Really,
really? There's not a game called
asterisk histories. Okay, let's see what,
what happened here? Um, oh,
asterisk within capital a
think that's how it goes down.
Session is not defined.
Okay.
Okay?
So I defined it in here. Oh, right.
So in the unit function, I've got to
say, I've got a number of actions,
switch probability,
appoint one
session number of actions
and then
interesting.
Hold on. Oh Shit. Okay.
All right. Let's see here.
I see how everybody's doing by the way.
Oh yes. I only have one ass.
See this is when it's good to,
okay.
Oh right.
Session number of actions with
probability, Dah Dah, Dah, Dah.
What's the issue
where on what line online,
36 sessions not to find,
oh,
you know what it is is I think I
forgot to add session to the um,
oh one s that's what it was.
Object takes no parameters.
The object takes no
parameters. Um, let's see.
Session number of actions
in the environment.
That action space off an
switch probability is too
return basic agent session environment.
Um,
you know what it is is,
um,
I think it's like this function
needs to go inside of the class 32,
right? Line 32. Yup.
Maybe it's like that.
Interesting. Okay. We've got,
we've got much more to do here.
We've got our visualizations,
we've got our plotting.
I've actually,
where's my coat here?
This is how we do it.
Okay. There we go. With all
my beautifully commented code,
by the way.
Definitely check this out.
Okay.
Yes. Good. All right.
Now let's try this thing.
All right. So, uh, the basic
runner that we defined earlier,
we're going to run the experiment and
that's going to train this thing and then
when we're done,
we can say we're done training.
That's simple. It's training. Okay. Let
me answer some questions. Like I said,
Q and a time.
All right.
What are the questions for today?
Okay.
There's some delay here between
comments and where I am. You know,
he's like a 15 second delay,
so it'll take a while.
Let's answer some questions here.
Okay.
Neil degrasse Tyson is this Roger Vol
of astrophysics. Thank you though.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
What application do you use for live
sessions, open broadcasting service, obs?
How do you create your own
environment? Great question. Um,
that would be using pie game to
create a game environment. Um,
you can use unity. Unity is great. Unity
has MLA agents, so it's just Google unity,
m l agents.
Great Framework for both mobile games
and desktop games and web applications.
And the third question is do people
use LSTM is on our l problems? Yes.
Long term memory is very important and
they do use it for sequential learning.
Specifically
did Q was a convolutional network,
but an Lstm in the context
of reinforcement learning
would probably be in a text
based environment or um,
yeah, one of those uh, tech
space environment makes
sense. Laptop battery 11%.
Yes.
Uh,
one more question.
Okay.
Is it possible to do our el Que learning
from scratch to learn more accurately?
So, uh, from scratch. Interesting.
Interesting point there.
So Mark Haub decision processes like this
idea is going to follow us throughout
the course.
It's going to follow off throughout all
of reinforcement learning and those mark
Javian variables that I talked about in
the beginning, right? These, the states,
the actions that transition probabilities,
the discount factor,
the reward not,
we're not always going to know what the
transition probabilities are going to be.
We're not always going to know what the
optimal state value function with the
optimal action value function.
We're not going to know always what
they're going to be and that means that
we're going to have a partially
observable mark Haub decision process.
So we have partial Upserve,
we have partial insight
into what's happening and so
we have to learn the rest.
And so all of,
we're starting off with art model based
methods where we know what the model of
the environment fully is going to be,
but sometimes we don't know
what that model is going to be.
So we're going to think we're going to
need to use model free techniques and cue
learning is one of them. And I am not
going to talk about Q learning yet.
I'm specifically avoiding it
right now because I, like I said,
those five concepts you've got to master
before you go into queue learning.
All right? It's like
that meme, like you know,
dive straight into get hub models without
understanding the math that people are
sharing, you know, whatever.
But like you gotta understand.
Let's go over those five things.
Again,
this is the five things you
need to remember from this
live stream. By the way,
the policy,
the state's value function,
the action value function,
the bellman equation,
and the mark of decision process.
Okay.
Okay. So where were
we? We train that baby.
It's done training.
Yup.
And now we can load the
baseline data. Okay. Um,
that's it. That, that, that's,
that's the most important part.
So what we're gonna do is,
um,
where are we at? Time
wise? 51 minutes. Okay.
Uh, this tense or board thing
is pretty cool. But yeah,
I, I like, I like dopamine.
Dopamine is cool. I mean,
clearly it's useful. Look,
if the Google researchers decided that
this was useful for them and they've got
a, you know, all the data, they've
got all the computing power,
they've got some of the best
researchers in the world,
then I think that that's good enough
proof that this is a good framework.
And also just looking at the code and
how it's structured though the, um,
the decisions they made
an architect the code.
I like this framework and I was
skeptical at first, I will admit.
But the more I looked at it and I've
been kind of deepen this for the past two
days, um, the more I
like it. So, um, and I,
and I really liked this idea of just
giving us this link right here of like
really quickly just checking
for any of these environments,
how each of these perform.
Not even that it's super necessary,
but just the fact that they did that.
Google has really been helping, um,
the greater amateur AI research
community lately with the Dataset search,
uh, with, um, colab. So, uh, yeah,
we're all very appreciative. Google,
if you're watching in, in, in this school
of Ai Community, we're very appreciative.
Thank you. So, um, yeah, uh,
let's load the baseline data.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm just going to do this. Here's
what, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to go straight into the,
just so you know, we'll do this together.
We'll go straight to dopamine, will
go to dopamine, will go to Colab,
we'll go to,
uh,
this colab lab that they have right here
and
these packages,
okay,
we can install just like this.
And then we can visualize them.
Okay. Uh, let me answer some questions
as well. While this is running,
dopamine is a happy hormone hormone.
Is it a hormone? Dopamine is more of,
I guess you could classify it as a
neuro transmitter along with serotonin.
And uh,
that's another one that's
for anxiety. I forgot. Uh,
can you, can you use dopamine with
real life or El Problems? Yes, you can.
Can you summarize what we've
accomplished so far? So,
so far we have trained and RL agent
using a random policy in the asterisk,
asterix environment. Uh, it,
we've trained it to learn an optimal
policy by choosing actions randomly.
Right? It's a very simple agent, but
we don't have to create our own agent.
What we could do is just a
subclass and existing agent.
And uh,
once we subclass and existing agent,
we can extend it like what rainbow did
or what the implicit Quan title agent
did. They just extended deep too. And
that's really the value that that brings.
Yeah.
As you can tell, I'm an ra, I'm really
trying to avoid coding out this last bit.
I just think that it's already out there.
We can just like compile it right now
if these dependencies take their time.
But I think in terms of a visual element,
um,
wow. It's already on. It's already loading
the baseline data. Pretty cool. Okay. Um,
right.
We've got to import our utils are
globals the game and then we can load the
baseline data.
Let me keep answering some
questions here if I have that up.
All right. You know what? I'm going to
end this stream with a rap. Um, but yeah,
visuals, visualization tools are
here. I'm not going to wait forever.
Waste your time with like loading the
stuff. Um, they've got a bunch of colab.
You've got my co lab. My lesson is
available in the video description.
Please subscribe if you haven't yet. I'm
going to continuously be posting, uh,
machine learning, deep learning,
reinforcement learning,
AI content on this channel. Um,
tell all your friends to subscribe.
We're almost at 500 k subscribers.
I cannot wait. I can taste it.
I can taste 500 K it's so close. And
I'm going to end this with a, with a,
a wrap. So just say a topic.
I'm going to wrap that topic.
All right.
Which will,
when Arele versus supervisor,
that's a great. Um,
there is no winner. They're both going
to win together. They're, they're,
they're both techniques are all,
they're both part of a larger,
whole of a learning
agent in an environment.
Right.
Okay.
Now,
yeah,
it's in the various,
yeah.
Okay.
Kind of love math. I mean, I do
it every day. I look at equations,
I look at everything, man. It's
okay. Listen, I was looking at RL.
I was looking at policies. I was
looking at all these things. Men,
it just got to me. I had
to stop. I had to think,
what are these value functions really
doing? When I was looking at them, man,
I was like, I was back in school
and I was writing on a chalkboard.
I was trying to code it out.
Look at how policies and values
relate to each other. Without a doubt.
I was trying to see what
the real meaning of it was,
how it all connected to each other,
how it was all a part of me,
like my cousin in it was like my
family member. Math is like my family.
And just like you guys, man, we do it
right. We do it actual liquor. Okay.
That's it. See, I always end
on a crazy note like that,
but thank you guys so much for watching
more live streams every single week. Um,
I'm in it for you and yes,
I've got 6% laptop battery. Uh,
and for now I've got to do a
bunch of school of AI work,
so thanks for watching.
All right.